Welcome back, Master Bart!
Hello, everybody!
Do you like the intro?
Hello, welcome, welcome, welcome in!
Welcome back to Metal Gear Solid PS4!
Apparently last night...
I don't remember posting that.
I think maybe I became possessed.
I don't know.
But I...
I posted that.
I'm like thinking, when...
What got me to post that?
Any alcohol?
No, I don't drink.
Hmm...
Mysterious.
You've got a great intro.
No problem, thank you so much for the 10 gifts.
Thank you!
Who is this piece and why we're walking them?
Actually, let's pause.
Yeah, you've got a great butt.
Yeah, that's what Solid Snake says.
Yeah...
I blame you for what 4MeFeed has been like on Twitter this morning.
What do you mean?
You create your own 4U, no?
It's 4U!
Not 4Me, not because of me.
It's literally in the name!
It's not me!
Nah, 4U, the viewer.
Anyway, I'm going to be 100% honest with you guys.
I think I've overworked a little bit.
And I am so tired.
And I...
I'm so tired of...
I had another meeting this morning.
And so I...
Right now, I'm on like maybe...
40% energy.
So...
Shut up!
I don't need your sass!
God, you're so rude!
My voice is dead because of pollen.
Hate you.
God, ViviCore, thank you so much for the gift.
And don't hate you.
So...
I can't wait to be carried by...
In this game again.
And...
Oh man, I really just want to close my eyes and sleep.
But I don't.
Because I have another collab tonight.
But...
So...
Thank you so much for the 20 gifts.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Pollen is a real struggle.
I need to stop going outside.
The butt eater.
No, no, no.
Unless...
I'm trading some rank B guys if you want them.
You're trading your men like Pokemon cards.
When are you and Snake getting married?
We're gonna get married...
At the wedding.
When the priest says, does anyone object?
Speak now, forever hold your peace.
Someone's gonna say me.
And of course it's gonna be Revolver Ocelot walking through the door.
He's gonna be spinning his little guns and he's gonna say, I object.
And then he's gonna take Snake away.
And I'm gonna be like, oh my god.
Who could have seen this happening?
And then...
I'll be like, oh but...
It's for the best, that's what I'll think.
If you love him, let him go.
If he comes back to you...
He wanted to stay, but he doesn't come back.
It was just meant to be, the two of them.
I'll be Miss Haversham for the rest of my afterlife.
Well, in this scenario I'm probably alive.
I'll be Miss Haversham for the rest of my life.
And I'll be like, sitting in my mansion with my old wedding cake on the table.
Be like, one day Snake will come back to me.
I was not expecting NTR Yaoi Fan Fiction Live on stream today.
It's not fan fiction, this is real.
This is what will actually happen...
When Snake and I get married.
Maybe Solid Snake will comfort me, it really just depends.
I don't know.
I'm not a mind reader.
I'm not a psychic, I can't tell the future.
Congratulations on my divorce.
On my divorce RTA.
lol
Congrats on getting left at the altar by your OTP.
Yeah, honestly, I think it would be like an honor for me to be like...
Well, at least my OTP is happy.
I guess it's...
What happened to Psycho Mintus?
Dead.
This is your pharmacist speaking.
You forgot to pick up your meds.
Oopsie!
Oh, wait, I winked but you couldn't tell.
Because I'm wearing an iPad.
It's your boy.
Tell Raiden's birthday yesterday.
Jeff!
Instead of traditional MGS, can I get Happy Birthday to you?
You live in a zoo, you look like a minky and you smell like one too.
Jeff!
Towel Raiden!
Oh my god!
Happy Birthday to you.
You live in a zoo.
You look like a minky and you smell like one too.
Happy Birthday!
Are you gonna be Towel Raiden again at MGS Con?
Don't come to my panel wearing that, please.
Please don't.
Don't do it again, please.
Don't come to my panel wearing that.
Jeff, you got it.
No, please don't.
Anyway.
Welcome back to Metal Gear Piece Walker.
Let's load the game so we're not just listening to...
I played a little bit off stream.
Let me show you some updates everybody.
Important updates.
Thank you boss.
Maybe Off Guy.
Maybe MGS Guy.
Off Guy?
What?
I have some people.
Oh no, where did I put him?
Wait, he's here.
Somewhere.
He's here somewhere.
Hold on.
Hold.
Oh wait, what did I just do with him?
Wait, Ant?
I lost Ant.
Ant?
Wait, where did he go?
I lost Ant.
Ant!
No!
What did I press?
I accidentally pressed A.
This guy is kinda good.
Hold on.
No he's not.
Nevermind.
Oh, I just got rid of him too.
Where did I put them?
In combat.
Oh there he is.
No, go back to the waiting room.
Who was the other guy I just got rid of?
Was it you?
No?
Whatever, it's fine.
Nidorgar Salad Tree.
Close.
I thought I literally just released them into the wild.
I was like, that's not possible.
Oh look, this is...
This is Nimi Nightmare.
I know.
Combat Sambo.
CQC?
This I gotta see.
Nimi Nightmare is not very good, unfortunately.
Her stats are actually quite low.
It's our man!
Leech!
Leech is also... He's pretty good at eating.
He's actually... I think he has better stats than the last time I got Leech.
So, yippee!
I've been recruiting some guys.
I've been making some weapons.
And stuff.
Look, look, I'm working on things.
I'm making things.
Oh wait, I don't want to recruit some anymore.
What do you call a fake spaghetti?
An impasta!
Yeah, we're making progress.
But today, we play more.
Oh, and I did some... Hold on, let me show some side missions.
I did just a few.
Let's see.
Let's see, let's see.
The extra ops.
I didn't do all of them.
I only did a few.
Oh gosh, I'm in bad trouble if I keep going on it like this.
I didn't feel like doing any of the marksmanships.
I did like the Fulton recovery.
Oh, I only have this one, no?
Oh, obstacle demolition.
This one too.
I'm not doing this.
We can do this one as a team maybe.
But we're back here.
Wow!
Alex is out.
Thank you so much for the Haka Super.
What?
Age is 26.
I never intended to get into the Metal Gear series, but after just beating MGS1 for the first time like 10 minutes ago...
The series has another fan.
Hope you're proud of yourself.
I used your playthrough win stack.
Thank you!
Oh my gosh!
Thank you, thank you!
One of us.
Metal Gear.
Well, spoilers maybe if you only just beat MGS1.
Yeah, thank you so much for the Haka Super.
Really appreciate it.
I just got a dono, but I don't know if it was Murphy's or Gary.
Anyway, thanks both of you.
Okay, so we just beat Chrysalis.
We met Strangelove last time.
We met...
Last time we beat Pupa.
We're about to travel to the mine base because we gotta...
Oh, we're already here!
Oh my gosh, wait!
Oh my gosh, I just noticed where we are.
Head for the enemy's mine base and prevent the assembly of the Mammal Pod and Peace Walker!
Yeah baby, yeah baby, yeah!
So, as usual I'm playing on the Xbox.
If you wanna join me?
Come play with me.
Yeah, we did read Huey's love letter.
Poor guy.
Okey-dokey.
Global?
Come on in!
Anybody wanna join?
Come on in, come on in.
Snake!
Wow, we have Snake.
What do I have?
This should be fine.
This should be good.
Are we ready?
I think so.
Yeah, I think we're ready.
Unless...
Nah, I'm going with the team.
Are we ready?
Let's go baby!
Are you planning on playing the MGS Delta Snake Eater?
Of course!
Why would I not play Snake Eater?
After watching your stream, I really got into the series.
Have a good stream.
Thank you, Bald!
Thank you, thank you.
Thanks for the spoiler alert.
I'll catch the VOD.
Horsey.
We have a horse girl in our midst?
Chapter 3!
A nation reborn.
Snake.
How's the horse doing?
Not too bad.
You'd never know he was over 20 years old.
He was hers after all.
Seems like some part of her became a part of him.
Horse girl.
The platform and the cerebral AI are supposed to be assembled at an underground base disguised as a mine.
If my guess is right, both of them have already arrived and are being readied for final testing.
My boy.
OK!
My Peace Walker.
Uma Musume Crossover?
For what reason?
Destroying the AI.
Oh yeah.
Hello.
Hello, hello, hello.
I'm going up.
Get me.
I'm getting the upper.
There's a guy right there.
I'll get his butt.
I didn't get his butt.
I got his head.
Oh no, don't call.
I got him.
Thanks.
Oh my gosh, he fell asleep.
Did you see that?
He literally collapsed to the ground.
What are you getting?
Don't worry about it.
They're going to be stuck in a loop.
I got his butt.
He's fine.
See?
We're fine everybody.
Rise and shine.
I see a guy over there.
No co-op out.
I might have messed up.
Shoot.
Take his butt.
Down.
Good job.
What if I take him out?
We'll be fine.
We'll be fine most likely.
Hey, where are you friend?
Snake!
Oh there you are.
Hi.
All clear!
Is that guy on the roof?
What's he doing up there?
What?
Oh.
I'll get him too.
Oh, I didn't get him.
Oh,
this guy is still here.
Let me get him.
Hey!
Go to sleep!
What if I...
I have magazines.
Wait!
He didn't look at it.
No, no.
Come here.
Can I pick you up?
Wake up.
Wait.
Hold on.
Oh, I think I hear somebody.
A prisoner?
Wait Snake!
We got to go get the prisoner.
No!
Shut up guys!
We got to go get the prisoner.
It's fine.
You want the magazine?
That I'm holding.
Thanks!
I'll take him home.
He has good eyes.
Wait.
I want to jump into the hay.
Where... Wait.
Hold on.
Everybody.
How do you get up there?
Hey Snake.
Show me the way.
Show me the way Snake.
Through here?
No.
OK.
We are going the long way.
We are going the longest way.
OK.
We are going the long, long way.
Oh.
There we go.
Let's go into the hay.
Yeah.
OK.
Here we go!
No!
You made it!
There it goes.
It's my birthday today.
What just happened?
It's not too bad.
It's going to...
Ooga booga caveman style.
Cave mentor birthday.
He's going to go read the magazine.
Oh no!
There's a guy again.
Look at him.
He's so in love.
You got him.
Dang.
Yours are strong.
What should I do with him?
Yeah.
What do you guys think?
You think I'm here because I want to be?
OK.
You're not coming home with me.
You're not coming home with... OK.
Let's go Snake.
He doesn't even want to be here.
Where did that guy come from though?
Mystery.
Happy birthday though!
I think he just stayed there until...Oh we never grabbed him.
But we successfully used the magazine.
Loud.
Peace Walker!
Stinking kidnappers.
Cipher.
It's a sniper battle everybody.
Senplex, thank you so much for the sand gifted.
Thank you!
Oh there's so many.
You ready?
You ready for this?
In the next chapter?
In the next mission?
Sniper.
We got three new guys.
Let's go.
Skip.
I actually don't... Is it...
Just the guy?
It's just the guys for the next one though.
I think so.
I think.
Yeah, it's so nice that the snipers are the only... Truly, right?
Skip.
These are all the new things that we made.
Alright, let's add our new guys in.
Are you guys any good?
Gerbil.
I wish I could see the Loch Ness Monster or Quetzalcoatl once in my life.
Yammu!
We got her.
Wait, is she the... Oh the POW is a lady!
I used to work in the kitchen.
Whether it's guns or knives, just leave it to me.
Do you need a gun in the kitchen?
Ma'am, what does your kitchen experience have to do with...
Have to do with anything!
Megamouth Shark and Eagle Ray.
Very good team.
It's a tough kitchen.
Oh yeah, better to be safe than sorry.
So true.
I don't think we had anything to develop.
Or I mean, obviously we have a ton, but...
So...
I got the strike mark...
The strike marker 2?
Rank 2?
Before getting the rank 1.
Let's do...
I'm not gonna have any of these for the next mission, but...
They call it Hell's Kitchen.
I was... I've been getting recommended Hell's Kitchen.
Like the official YouTube channel.
Recently.
And so, they put up like really long episodes.
Like really long videos, so I'll put them on to sleep.
But oh my gosh, I cannot sleep with it because it's like...
The intro is just like...
It's so loud, it's like...
And I'm like, shut up!
I'm trying to sleep!
Gargoyle!
Thank you so much for the 10 gifted.
Thank you.
It's my day... of birth!
I don't need a song, I just want to say thanks for many hours of fun and I hope I can keep watching you be freaky for many years!
Fluffiness, thank you!
Happy birthday!
Are you sure you don't want a song?
Eliminate the guards.
Take them out before they take you out.
OK!
Alright, anybody wanting to play?
Take out the guards!
Come on in!
I think I've forgotten the basics of CQC but...
No you haven't!
Don't say that!
Who's in?
Rooks!
Welcome, welcome.
Let's see.
Do I need...
This is my sniper, but should I bring my...
Thank you everyone!
Should I bring a regular gun for the kidnappers and stuff?
You can non-lethal this if you want.
But the kidnappers, no?
They're kind of annoying.
Maybe we'll bring the sniper for the guards.
And then like...
M60 for the...
For the little drone guys.
They'll be too far to fall in.
I can run over there!
I think this is good.
Will you play Peace Walker again in the future?
I'm not able to play right now.
I mean, I will play...
Once we beat it.
I'll play until we beat it.
But I have no plans on... Maybe like as a members thing.
I suppose.
Like if we wanted to redo missions.
But I don't have any plans to go back through it again.
At least not the story, you know.
Probably like that.
Refight bosses.
True.
We were... It's not our fault we were spotted.
It's just...
It's not... I mean, maybe it is our fault.
We were just standing right out in the open.
No!
Stupid drone.
Oh my gosh, we're literally just sitting ducks.
Bom-bom.
Bom-bom-bom-bom-bom.
OK.
Alright.
Alright, rooks.
I... I missed.
I wish I had some...
I got him.
Ouch.
Where are you getting me from?
Oh my gosh.
A little guy almost got me.
No!
Why is my aim so bad?
I'm reloading.
He's running.
Oh, dammit.
Why did I think that would work?
Oh,
you should be asleep by now.
I'm going for him.
Stop!
Where
are you?
Rooks!
Oh, there you are.
Let's take out some...
I got him.
What did you get?
Wait, what did you get?
Wait, where are they?
Where are they?
Such tiny little men.
Hello?
People?
Where are they?
Oh, there they are.
Oh, they're coming up!
Oh my god!
Hold on.
I'm going to leave a magazine for them.
Nevermind.
You got this.
I'm going to also throw a...
I threw one too!
No!
No, no, that's me!
I'm getting kidnapped!
No!
You stinking...where did it go?
No, no.
No, no, I'm on the wrong thing.
There we go.
Oh, was that you?
Wait, who are you?
Oh, he's dead.
Where did you come from?
Yeah!
Take him down!
Bring him home!
Did I just kill a man?
My bad.
Wait a second.
I turned off notifications on Xbox.
What the hell happened?
No.
My bad.
Oh, when did they get that?
Oh, that's not good.
That's not...what is he...this guy is like shimmying away.
This guy is like doing the shimmy for real.
I don't have any fireworks!
I don't have any!
Stop running!
Damn it.
Oh, damn it.
Oops.
Don't shoot me please.
Ouch.
I really asked politely.
How are you awake again?
I need to eat some of my curry.
So...
Come
here.
Come here.
Where is everybody?
Oh, there is a guy.
Is that for me?
Oh, I took it.
Thank you!
I can't see anything now.
Game, I can't see.
Game, please.
Here they come.
More men!
More wisdom for the cause.
Where is...
Oh, they are on their way here.
Let's just wait for them, no?
We can CQC them, no?
I'll also throw a smoke grenade.
No!
Don't shoot!
You know you want to!
Come home!
Is this guy dead?
What's wrong with you?
He just faded out of existence!
What just happened?
It had a green skull over them though.
What happened?
Where is this mononoke?
Have fun Josh!
He was a ghost.
Don't...
Not yet!
I should have gotten him.
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
Where did that come from?
Oh you mister...
Oh you got him!
Wow!
Good job Rooks!
Good job!
0 out of 24!
24!
We did it!
Easy peasy.
Easy peasy lemon squeezy.
Alright, come on.
What's that sound?
It's not a good sound.
This guy is a big, big boy.
I don't understand.
This seems like the worst of the prototypes, no?
I feel like Chrysalis is the best one.
It's like so portable and fast.
This one is just a big clunky... Look at how slow he is!
They like progressed in technology.
Oh, I said cocoon again.
Cocoon!
Where was... Wait.
Gosh, they are so confusing.
I don't know biology.
Which comes first?
Sometimes size matters.
I mean he's got a lot of bullets on him.
And he's got a chainsaw.
Oh, cocoon!
OK, so it was Chrysalis and then cocoon.
Such a fun way to experience this game.
Thanks Rooks!
Thanks for playing with me!
The little chainsaw on a string is so funny.
Yeah!
We got 9 guys.
Let's go.
Compensation for something?
I don't know.
Let's get our guys.
And maybe this time we can do the strike...
Anti-tank mod.
Nice.
Analyzer.
A delivery!
Uh-oh, hair.
Girl.
What did I get?
Oops.
Did you get me?
This is the worst ever.
It was all empty mags.
Oops all mags.
Oh my god.
Chimpanzee.
The gibbon.
Gibbon trash.
I'm pretty tired so I might pass out, but if you do have full permission to put me over to your place...
Oh no, I feel asleep.
What are your stats?
It's not so easy.
I'm not running a daycare over here.
Throw it at cocoon.
I'm gonna take only...
Only that with me.
Let's see.
Is there anything that we could take?
No, I'll take the strike mark.
For 2.
I have 2.
So...
It's all lethal?
No.
So...
No, nothing else.
Will do.
Alright, 3 other lucky folks.
Who wish to...
Get through cocoon together.
Now is the time.
If we have to cause...
Ready?
Go!
Ready!
For broken buckets and for...
Sorry.
Welcome!
Alright, let's prep.
Prep up everybody.
Prep up.
Ouch!
No!
Going with the tea.
It's a Metal Gear staple to go with the tea.
We don't need the smoke grenade but we'll...
Is the chaff good for this one?
Gotta bring my empty mags.
The strike mark.
Tada!
And we'll bring the supply marker, that's important.
As long as we don't hear...
I love the beach!
I love that one, please!
Please!
I love the beach.
Nobody?
No one's gonna say I love the beach?
That's fine.
Chaff should be good.
Maybe instead of grenade we...
No,
I think this is OK.
Super M.
This should be good.
Alright, everybody!
Everybody!
Everybody, ready, ready, ready, Freddy!
Looks like two are ready.
Three are ready!
Let's go!
I love the beach.
Going with the tea.
Is that a Death Stranding reference?
The beach.
Are you guys having a good weekend so far?
Did you guys get to sleep in?
I had a meeting with my new tax person today.
Except it ended just a little bit before stream because she slept in.
But she's so nice.
Oh my gosh, I love my new tax person.
I have to work on Saturdays.
Oh no!
Good luck with work.
I have to wake up at 5AM.
Am I going to marry her?
I don't know.
I don't know if she's taking me on.
OP!
Pink pants!
Hey, who didn't get the memo here?
Someone is overdressed for the occasion.
Glad you got a good tax person.
My friend recommended her.
She's so nice.
Hey, you!
Hey, broken!
Alright!
It's so loud.
Get up, Snake.
Am I already... Oh my gosh, I'm already almost dead.
Ouchie ouch!
Hold on.
Rude.
No, no, no!
Run, Snake, run!
You guys got this.
You guys got this and... I don't know why.
This thing is so stinking slow.
I don't really need to...
Attack the pod!
I'll just go for some other stuff too.
Like that.
What happened to me?
What's happening?
Just then.
Hello?
Let's go downstairs.
Oh my god, the chainsaw!
Rude!
Get some of these other stinking, stinky guys out of the way.
If I can.
What is this?
What is the green gas?
I shouldn't have gone in.
Are we okay?
Hug the walls!
Oh my gosh, I thought that was about to kill me.
Yeah!
We got the ladder!
Good job, guys.
Nice.
Oh gosh, oh gosh, oh gosh.
That was close.
No!
I should have... I should have... I'm such an idiot.
We'll do it just in case now.
Take out the weapon!
I'll get it!
Gusto!
Oh
my gosh, Broken, are you okay up there?
Did I hit you?
I hope not.
Use the ladder.
Go underneath it.
I know what happens, but I'll go under.
Will it do it here?
Oh no!
Someone left some stuff over here.
Hello, you left your goods.
You left your goodies.
Wait, why did I just throw that?
I picked the wrong thing.
Hey, wait!
No way, this should have been me!
No!
You're the only one who I trust for the occasion!
Oh, I didn't get on top in time.
My best moment!
I need more stuff.
I
have team.
Oh, my stuff is literally dropping to the ground.
Please, please hold on.
I gotta run it.
I gotta run and catch it.
Actually, maybe I don't want the Fem.
Actually, I'm okay with the Fem.
We'll do Gusto instead.
Get lots of stuff in there, Broken!
I'll destroy some other things.
Wow, we're at it.
Main cannon!
Let's go!
Let's get some...
Wait, what just happened?
Is that it?
It was so fast!
Oops, I guess I died.
It was so strong.
It was so fast!
Did I get everything in there?
Watch out!
I like how the Mammal Pod just has it's own like...
It's own like...instincts.
Okay team.
Alright, I'm still the leader of this team.
No!
I've been reduced to second!
You're supposed to follow my lead!
No!
Why always this submission is so good?
Walk.
Power.
He's the captain now.
Oh
wait, I meant to go to the mission.
It's fine though.
Dj vu!
Power Zeke.
A new plant has been built thanks to staff efforts.
Delivery!
Really?
What girl?
Thank you, the flower.
Thanks mom, it's always a pleasure to match T-shirts with you.
Thanks alrighty!
Oh my gosh, wait!
I just realized you guys, today I'm wearing...
You can't tell it's underneath my maid uniform, but I'm wearing a Peace Walker T-shirt!
I'm wearing my white T-shirt!
I matched with Snake even!
I'm matching with Snake!
Thank you for the gift!
Wait, skip.
There we go.
And righty!
Thanks for the gift!
Thank you for the gifts!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
Curry.
Yummy snacks.
Thank you, thank you!
Nice, nice, nice.
Alrighty.
We're not done yet.
No ambulance box.
I have one.
Infiltrate the underground base.
Make your way to the bottom of the underground base and stop Peace Walker before it is complete.
Wait, is this the scene?
No.
I'm thinking of the Vic boss scene.
Is it this one?
Find Strange 11!
Go out with her!
That's later?
OK.
At the very bottom of the mine.
Infiltrate the base and put a stop to the project by destroying Peace Walker's AI pod.
OK!
Who would like to join me to destroy Peace Walker's AI pod?
Haven't survived close?
Maybe.
Oh, my favors!
Welcome back!
I guess I'll get out of my T-shirt even though it's very comfortable.
Stealth.
And we'll bring this guy again.
And Mark 22.
Stealth.
So much good teamwork in this stream.
Right?
Everybody's working so well together.
Happy, happy.
Alright.
We ready?
We ready, ready, ready, ready?
Hi, everyone.
Hello!
Ready to...
I'm gonna eat a cough drop.
I've been having them everyday.
I'm gonna have one now.
I hope you guys don't mind.
My throat hurts a little bit.
Which is unusual actually.
It doesn't usually hurt.
No, sneak in.
No, sneak out.
Sneak in only.
I actually don't remember this.
Even a little bit.
I actually don't remember this part even a tiny bit.
I think I... Did I just like forget this part ever existed?
Oops.
Why'd you have to run?
Nice, nice.
You're too fast!
Let me get one, please!
I want a man!
Stop!
I want one for myself.
Ok, I got him.
That guy is mine.
Don't steal my snack.
Where did I hear somebody at?
I don't remember this part at all.
Look!
I'm on top of the Metal Gear!
I'm on top!
Look at me!
Yeah, me too.
I know that the stealth suit makes it so that they can't hear your footsteps, but it still makes me...
Wait, where do we need to go?
It still makes me paranoid.
Because I can hear it, you know what I mean?
Is it here?
Where are we going?
I'm following you.
Should we take some of these guys?
Ok!
We're taking them home!
Welcome back!
Oh you have the special one.
Nice.
Ready?
Let's go!
I want that Fulton.
The one that drops their stuff too.
Let's go baby.
Why don't I remember this area at all?
I don't know.
Oh wait!
Now it's kinda coming back to me.
It's funny though that they don't have anything on them, you know?
You're a lady.
Let's go.
Oh!
Sorry, I got a little contact.
I got a little bit of a...wow.
Oh shoot.
No, no!
Good job.
I'll take you home too.
Oh shoot, that guy is running.
He's scaring me.
You got him?
Oh, I'm not gonna get you.
Nice hit!
Nice!
I'll do a flip to that.
Prisoner.
You got him?
They're coming!
Thank you!
I'll take him home.
You got him?
Good job.
Good job team.
Oh you're taking this guy.
We're gonna extract him too.
Him?
OK, I got him.
Oh wait, I pressed it.
What happened?
That was weird.
Sorry, I didn't mean for you to waste one.
Let's go!
Obligatory teabagging?
No!
We have quite a collection of men.
Hey mister.
Hey, why did you move?
I lost him.
He's so blind!
Stupid man!
Stupid!
I don't think we want to extract him.
That guy is not gonna be of any use to us.
That guy is blind as a bat.
Hey!
What did you just...
Where's the other guy at?
Oh he's all the way down there.
Oh he's got a shield.
And his buddy does too.
How are they so blind?
I got him.
I'm getting praised you guys!
Happy day!
You want me to get him?
Don't kill him.
Wait, I kind of want to have a go at him.
No!
How could you?
Can I look at your boobs real quick?
Turn around?
Nice!
Oh sorry.
Let's go.
Wait, where is it?
This way?
Oh!
Down here.
Come on!
I didn't want to auto him!
I'm pushing!
Wayfarer...
Ok, I'm done pouting now.
Is this...
Is this testing for me for later?
For maybe a potential...
You know, first butts and now boobies.
Yippee!
It's a great day!
What was I going to say?
A little foreshadow.
Strange love!
Look how beautiful she is.
Strange love.
QTE coming.
Thank you for the warning.
I totally...
How did they get up there so fast?
Jack, you've returned.
What's wrong?
Your body temperature has fallen.
You're imagining things.
Have you come to destroy me?
Your pulse has quickened slightly.
Just chilly.
It's freezing in here.
I see.
Boss.
What is it, Jack?
Boss, is that you?
Do you have regrets?
Regrets?
About your final mission.
My final mission?
The one in Krasnograd.
I've never been on a mission there.
September 1964.
You betrayed the United States.
And then...
I killed you.
I have no record of such a debriefing.
Listen to me.
I have to know.
Did you defect to the Soviet Union of your own free will?
There is no mission record matching that description.
Jack.
You're not the boss.
The boss is dead.
Don't do it, Jack.
Drop your weapon, Big Boss.
Mammals showed the same response back at the lab.
It's a sure sign that you are nearby.
Excuse me.
It's an honor to meet you again, Big Boss.
I've seen that coyote before.
That's a coyote?
Lobo is the name.
Lobo?
It smells like a rotting corpse to me.
I know all about you.
Selina Yarsk.
Ten years ago.
You were involved.
The operation to eliminate the traitor.
I planned the whole thing.
Shouldn't a suit like you be back in Langley?
What the hell are you doing here?
It's what the CIA does best.
Ensure people in the know keep their mouths shut.
Or else pack them off someplace where there's no one to listen.
How come that looks like such a weenie and how is he so strong?
It's not quite that simple.
My aim is a new world order.
Detente, the NPT.
Salt, TTBT.
Ever since the Cuban Missile Crisis, the structure of the Cold War has been coming apart at the seams.
A new age is dawning.
An age in which Peace Walker, an infallible nuclear deterrent system with the patience and cold logic of a machine, will play a vital role.
That's your plan.
Assigning humanity's sins to a bunch of machines?
Quite the romantic.
Remember the Cuban Missile Crisis?
When the commander of a Russian sub refused an order to launch a nuclear-armed torpedo at an American destroyer?
Oh history.
In retrospect, that man was a hero.
He saved the world from all out nuclear war.
Humans are incapable of destroying themselves.
But an AI wouldn't hesitate to push the button.
Precisely.
Making it the one real deterrent.
People hesitate, lose their nerve.
Isn't that why deterrence theory works in the first place?
No.
Machines don't make mistakes.
That's why I love when Google AI tells me to put cement on my salad as a dressing.
Once our system is embraced, Langley will again turn its attention to Latin America as the cockpit of a new Cold War.
Honduras, Nicaragua, Costa Rica, Panama...
Peace Walker will be deployed along Central America's entire Caribbean coast.
All of North America, South America, and the West Indies will be within its range.
We'll bring law and order to the entire continent.
And you'll still be calling the shots?
You still don't get it.
The age of heroes is over.
Bury it alongside the boss and her bankrupt beliefs.
From now on, our only heroes will be machines.
Surely no one understands that better than you.
Except perhaps your partner.
A deterrent for hire.
An army without borders.
You've invented a new system too?
And an admirable one at that.
It is admirable.
That's supposed to be an offer.
I'm not offering anything.
If I'm to sell my new system, you and yours have got to go.
Wait!
Coldman, I have questions for him.
Information critical to the completion of the mammal pod.
Give him to me.
Don't waste too much time.
We've just received word that the SALT II talks are on schedule.
We will launch on time.
Snake, you are going to help me resurrect her.
Shut up!
The boss is dead.
Bring him.
I got him.
RT!
Over!
Why?
Oh shit I've got it wrong.
Oh no!
No!
I pressed RT instead of Y.
Nice punch.
It's OK.
Game over!
Someone sent a super chat earlier about how they don't like that in MGS3 it's very clear what the boss' intentions were.
But in this game, it's like they say that she defected or this and that.
And I think it's...
I think it's...
I think maybe this is why people complain about Peace Walker.
It's not my favorite aspect of it.
But it's...
Yeah, it's really Snake's...
Snake kind of gets into his own head about it.
I think he's just so overcome with guilt that...
You know, even Strangelove...
Strangelove tries to convince him like...
Hey man, you remember what happened?
You were there.
And he's just like...
No, she defected.
And she's like...
No, that's not the real story.
They fed you lies.
But also at the same time, I feel kind of conflicted about it because I'm like...
Why would you believe...
Like you left the US because you were so upset about it.
Why are you believing them?
But at the same time, they kind of just need him to become like a villain.
They kind of need him to become like his little villain arc so that they can have...
You know...
Outer Heaven happen and all that stuff.
How do you interpret the boss' will?
Hmm...
Lady was cool.
Everybody always is just misinterpreting the boss.
Pretty much.
Wow, we got 14 guys!
But yeah, it's kind of confusing because you see how the end of...
How his reaction is at the end of...
End of 3.
But then you see him in this game and he's become like this little...
Pathetic baby who's just like...
No!
The boss...
The boss defected.
Why'd you do that?
But you know...
I want to slap a slice of cheese on the bald guy's chrome dome.
Yeah...
He was always a baby.
It's so true.
He's my little guy.
But also, it's been a long time since 3, so...
He probably...
Oh, thanks for the delivery!
He probably also is just like...
So in his head at this point.
Thanks, Wayfarers!
Go, go, go!
Thank you!
Go,
go, go!
Thank you so much for the gifts!
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Alright, let's sort our guys again.
Who do we have here?
Warthog.
When I was a young warthog.
Polar bear.
I have a guy.
I don't know if it was on stream or if I...
I'm former sass.
But...
Wow, Flamingo's cracked at cooking.
But he had literally nothing written on his thing.
The low rank 2!
Let's grab that.
Nice.
Nice, nice, nice.
Um...
You know what?
I'll just get these guys.
Why not?
What other items do we have?
Curry!
Mate!
Lovebox 3!
Important.
You know what?
I'll even get the Walkman.
Let's just get everything at this...
You know what?
Let's just get all the items.
Yay!
OK.
Nice.
Curry.
Curry, curry, curry.
Torture chamber escape.
I need to lay down for a while.
My memory...
Wait, I can do this.
Not just by myself.
That's kind of funny.
Welcome back!
We have no mission prep.
We're all by ourselves.
So sad.
Let's go then.
We got nothing to lose.
He's a pro at escaping prison.
O.S.P.
My thumbs are in danger.
I know!
Oh gosh!
OK.
Micmac, you've played this one.
You've played this game, so you know.
I think this one is hard.
Torture is more difficult than MGS1.
That's just my opinion.
I think.
I feel like it was.
I don't remember though.
We'll see.
Maybe I've improved.
I think the MGS1 one is so easy.
I had my lady swimsuit and they didn't let me equip it.
No!
OK, join for another one.
No.
A BGM.
Loyalty to your country or loyalty to me.
Your country or your old mentor.
Your mission or your beliefs.
Your duty to your unit or your personal feelings.
The only thing we can believe in with absolute certainty is the mission, Jack.
Rise and shine.
Coldman's greed does not concern me.
I'm only interested in one thing.
The truth.
I'm a scientist, an AI developer.
But not an AI myself.
I'm a scientist, and as a scientist I find this distasteful.
You understand?
I am a scientist, and I expect answers that make sense.
Now, what do you know?
Your boss defected from the US taking a Davy Crock with her.
And used it to launch a nuclear strike on Soviet territory.
That much I know from the CIA's official debriefing.
Did she defect or not?
Answer me!
Did she or did she not die for her country?
That's why there's no info about that mission because she doesn't know.
She doesn't want to put in the wrong information.
She sold us out.
My orders were to take care of her.
Liar!
I want to know the truth!
Brace yourself.
Okay, what do I press?
Oh god, it's so long.
You hate me?
Fine.
Turn it up.
It doesn't change the fact that I killed her.
I know that.
But what I don't know is your motive.
Why would a hero, loyal to the end, betray her country?
What really happened?
What did you see?
She betrayed more than just her country.
She betrayed me too.
Then how do you explain that bandana?
Why keep a memento of a traitor?
What are you talking about?
And what about that scar?
Don't tell me you have the same scars by sheer coincidence.
Don't touch me!
Decorating your body with her memory.
Rather effeminate, if you ask me.
Answer me!
No!
It's so long.
Ouchie.
Why won't you tell me?
You're no longer one of Washington's lapdogs.
You have no moral obligation to your country.
Answer me!
Would you see your beloved boss brought back to life?
Then say it.
Say she died for America.
That she remained true to the end.
Gave her life for the country that betrayed her time and again.
No.
What if he admits that?
Then he has to admit that he killed her for... for nothing.
She went to her grave, cursing her country.
No!
Snake!
Why?
Who is it?
What are you protecting?
I'm not helping you finish that thing.
Face it.
The boss is dead.
Whatever's inside that machine, it isn't her.
I think Snake has just started to like this kind of thing.
The next one, I kill you!
No!
Something's going on outside.
That one wasn't so long.
Abort the mission.
We have a man down.
Are you kidding me?
Micmac?
Real sorry boss?
Wait, can I skip this?
Don't die on me Micmac!
Come on!
Skipping!
I've never seen that cutscene though.
I've never seen that cutscene.
It hurts!
Oh my god.
I started pressing B instead of Y.
He's passed out.
Ok, back on track.
I trusted you.
I had to do this twice.
Wow, this looks like poops all of a sudden.
Hello poops.
It's like poops, no?
Actually I don't remember how to...let's see what we have.
Sunrod.
Where are you Micmac?
That's horrible.
I can't fault him yet though.
Wait, I'm just chilling here.
Wait, hold on.
I've got to wait for this guy.
He's not going to notice, right?
Hello.
Stop.
Go away.
Hello.
Can you leave?
Why does he look so like...he's like...
Nothing to see here.
My bad.
Sorry.
Sorry!
Wait, we don't have to go through...
It again, right?
Please God, no.
Not the torture sequence again.
Even Steven!
Ok, we're fine.
We're fine.
Everything is good.
My hand...I'm just, you know, I'm in such...
I'm in such bad state because, you know...
Because, you know...
I just was...I had to do the torture sequence.
Just, you know, it like really hurt my hand so bad.
Oh good, now he goes another way.
There's so many guys here.
I'm out!
I'm free!
I'll come back for you maybe.
Wait, how do I leave?
How do I get out of this?
You hear
that?
What's going on?
Oh my God.
You hear that at the distance?
It's so funny.
Hold on, this is my guy.
I'm gonna get him.
I'm waiting.
I'm waiting for him to leave.
I got his butt.
Where are you Mick Mack?
Oh, that's not you.
That's not...
Bring who in?
Oh...
Talk.
He doesn't know anything.
Useless!
There's still a guy over here.
We got to get him though.
Maybe.
And there's also a prisoner next to me.
There's two guys here.
OK, you take down one.
I got the other.
He's gonna come over here.
You got him?
Nice.
Yeah.
Oh my God!
Mine will be just as violent.
You didn't know anything?
He said I'm pretty good.
OK, I want him.
He's a keeper.
Where do we get our stuff Mick Mack?
Don't do that to him.
Get up.
Come on.
Where do we go?
This way.
Down here.
Wait, but the prisoner...
Oh, I'm running into the wall.
Over this way?
Yeah.
Wait, this way.
Come on.
Let's go.
Keeping him warm.
Hot cold man.
He is such a weenie.
We got the A.S.S.
music!
Let's go A.S.S.
When is the next time gonna be anyway?
There is such a pat.
Are you OK Snake?
Snake?
Don't make me laugh.
No smoking for you for a while, huh?
I'll be fine.
The pain in my chest is gone.
So that was just a copy of the boss's wound.
That's right.
The scar is gone now.
Nice work.
My baby!
My baby girl!
Why are those in quotes?
Skipping school.
Pause!
You're great!
No!
Jesus!
Please!
Come on!
Don't skip school!
Chaos It's like it's waiting for us.
It's like it's waiting for us or something.
Ah!
Yay!
I'm just gonna hit you with the yo-yo.
OK, we made some new things.
Oh a delivery for me?
Whatever could it be?
Happy birthday!
Nice.
What did you give me?
Stealth mat.
No!
Away from me!
Big Mac!
Men's cologne!
Future curry!
Oh we got those!
Oh my gosh!
You sent me some really fancy things.
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you.
Future!
Future, future, future!
Is it this mission?
Is this the one?
Or is it... Soon.
I know it's very soon.
Speaking of pause, how was Pause the Cat?
She was so needy.
She was so needy right before stream.
I barely wanted to leave her.
I know, she just kept wanting to... She would like meow at me.
And then like run... She runs to like a certain room and then she like plops on the floor and wants to be pet.
She's so funny.
Let her in?
If I let her in, she'll want to out immediately though.
Yeah, she was cute.
OK.
I don't think it's this one.
Who wants to join?
Mobius!
Welcome, welcome.
How do we get our stuff back?
I wonder.
Maybe we should have walked around and find a...
Fulton in that one area maybe.
Guess who's back.
Welcome back.
I probably don't need you.
We'll bring...
Just in case.
Are we ready?
Looks like we're ready.
Let's go!
Starting mission.
For the one mission, I don't know if you guys know what I'm referring to.
There's a mission with a song.
For that one.
Getting stuff back is an extra ops mission.
Thanks for the KDA.
For that mission, I want us to...
How do I say?
I want us to enjoy the atmosphere.
I don't think it's this one.
Welcome, Mobius.
Lucky!
There's a bunch of guys here.
A bunch of little men.
Why is this acting so weird?
Why can't I...
Gosh, I really struggled with that one.
I think you'll notice.
Actually, I think I'm doing the covering, Mobius.
Nevermind, I'm falling.
Hold it?
OK.
Good job.
Wait, there's another guy.
There he is.
Watch out.
I got him.
Bolton recovery helicopter is complete.
Thanks!
I'll take him too.
Which way are we going?
We need to go...wait.
We can go either way?
OK, cool.
Bolton recovery subject confirmed on board helicopter.
Let's go!
Bolton recovery helicopter is complete.
Does it matter which way we go?
What does...oh wait.
What's in the torture chamber?
Mysterious.
Mysterious, mysterious, mysterious.
Love that we got to do all these again.
OK.
Where is he?
Where the heck is he?
Oh I see the guy down there.
OK.
Oh I see him right there.
You got him?
I'm trying to get this guy, but I'm too short.
I'm too short for that man.
Oh wait, I can get him here.
I got him.
Prisoner!
I got you.
I think we just stole a lady.
Kazuhiro Miller, you dog!
You ready?
We don't have to get the guy down there.
It's OK.
I'm going to scoot over just a tiny bit.
There we go.
That should be better.
Sorry.
I got you.
Nice!
Wait, I can get him?
You're going to get him?
Are you sure?
I kind of want to get him.
I had him.
Oh, I didn't have him.
Oh, I didn't have him again.
Mobius, you got this.
Get his butt.
Hey, don't go.
Sorry.
I used up all my points.
In the previous rooms.
Thanks for the stuff!
I used up all my skill points in the previous room.
Where is he?
Come on!
Nice.
What the?
I was like, what happened to you?
That's so funny.
Let's take him.
Let's go down the stairs.
Oh there are two of them here.
It corrected.
Nice.
Thanks!
What?
Somebody was talking.
Where was he?
Guess not.
Is that a person over there or what?
I'm going to extract them too.
Come over here.
I'll show you.
Oh, ok.
Ok.
Nice.
Slowest teabag in history.
He got his soda.
Let's take that.
Zero calories.
I got this guy earlier.
Is there
anything else we missed?
I think that's it, right?
Right?
Oh wait, the other side.
I think.
I think
there is another prisoner in the office.
In this one?
No, there wasn't anybody in here.
Yeah.
It's ok.
Let's go.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
All good.
Impressive.
What if it's a nerd stuffed in a locker?
Well...
Maybe it deserves to be in there.
No!
What?
She finished it so fast.
She fulfilled her duty to America to the very end.
Thanks to you, Snake.
The final missing piece is now in place.
And thus, the boss is restored to life as the normal part.
I thank you.
The art is so great.
You're crazy.
I'll let you in on a little secret, big boss.
You see, I've already selected Peace Walker's initial target.
An offshore area in the Caribbean.
The trade winds will scatter the fallout all over the surrounding region.
Crops and fish will die, leaving plenty of free hands to help us mass produce Peace Walker.
So messed up.
And wouldn't you know, someone's gone and built a pesky little fortress there.
Now who would do that?
I'm right in the middle of the target zone too.
Oh well, all the better to test the warhead, CEP.
You bastard.
I wonder who will miss a ragtag band of pirates all the way out in the middle of the Caribbean.
But first, we're going to prove to the White House that our baby can travel the Caribbean coast on its own.
The whole world will know of Peace Walker's versatility.
They'll witness the birth of a deterrent that can penetrate both Communist and guerrilla-controlled territory, traverse any kind of terrain, and deliver a nuke anywhere it needs to go.
Untouchable.
Unstoppable.
The perfect deterrent.
The Cold War's days are numbered.
Deterrence isn't only about America and Russia now.
You know what?
You're absolutely right.
While we've been wringing our hands, China, France, even India have surpassed us.
There's a free-for-all nuclear arms race brewing just below the surface.
The nuclear threat will only spread, which is exactly why we must deter it here and now.
He's such a freak.
The Peace Walker Project is the key.
The advent of Peace Walker will bring calm to this restless world.
Don't you see, Snake?
We need nukes, controlled nukes, to have peace.
Lies!
Peace Walker will restore order.
Order in the form of a new Cold War.
But if the world is to understand the genius of our plan, we must launch.
Uh-oh.
Snake!
Run, run, run, run.
Poor paws.
Little baby.
We must lunch.
Sandwiches for all countries.
Sign of potato chips.
Snake, I think you're gonna need a bigger gun.
Look at him just staring at it.
Peace Walker.
Failed, deadly, AI controlled.
Is this a walking tank?
The music is so good.
More like Peace Hobbler.
This thing is so slow.
Snake!
Uh-oh.
Why didn't you say that beforehand?
Target suppression mode.
Right now, Peace Walker's highest priority target is you.
Here it comes.
The time has come and so has Peace Walker.
Ta-da!
To be continued.
Sorry.
Trying to wake up a little bit at least.
My money is on mint.
Really?
Nice!
11 people vaulted.
Let's go.
I should bring...wait, I should what?
I should have brought...my Raptor?
What's that?
That's it.
I have to go to the little ghosties room in a second, but then we'll of course...
I wonder if the law, the new law has...
Smelt!
Holy moly.
Wait, ok, hold on.
Let's see if our weapons...
Ah!
65%!
No!
So close.
Oh well.
More mate.
He must have dealt it.
Let's see our lovely ladies.
Oh Bob, why?
She's burning...wait, we got two Axolotls and one...
One of them is going to have to die.
Firefly.
Wait!
Of Honkai fame we have Firefly?
Oh my god!
On my mother base?
Wow.
Wow, Duckyball.
Where's Ducky?
You guys are so stupid.
Gecko, Bobwhite...
Wait, we have two Bobwhites also!
What's going on here?
We have normal Bobwhite and...
Wait, what's going on?
How did this happen?
What?
Skunk?
Oh that's what the guy smelt.
Gamboja?
What the hell is that?
There's Bob's terribles.
Oh nice.
Wait, we actually have some new stuff.
Wait, why can't I assign Bob?
Wait, you're good in R&D.
Is my R&D...
My R&D team is full!
Ok, hold on.
Let's take out some poopy guys.
Who's our lowest ranking?
Oh, everybody's kind of leveled up so they're all pretty good.
It must be you though.
What else do you have good?
Food.
I'll send you to the mess hall.
Oops, and then...
Yeah, you're really good.
Let's get you in R&D.
Ok, nice.
We had like so few things.
Stun gun!
Hmm...
I know we had the shield.
I don't really use the shield.
I don't really use the sonic eye either much.
I just go on instinct, baby.
Ok, give me one second guys.
I'm going to use the little ghost's room.
And then we shall fight.
We shall fight.
Actually, I'm also going to grab more of some drinks.
Ok.
Ok, I'll be right back.
Give me one second.
I've got to send something real fast.
We are good.
Let's go.
Mission selector!
Cat petted.
Absolutely.
The music!
Stop peace walker.
Ok.
Who's ready to fight for peace?
Four paws!
My cat.
What did you catch fish in?
I caught a mutated gar and a mutated salmon.
Very exciting.
Thank you for the gift.
Thank you.
Thank you guys for all the chat too while I was gone.
Ok.
Host.
Gone with the tea.
Welcome Nero Mobius.
Perky boy.
Welcome.
Gone with the tea.
Going with the wisps too fast.
Sorry.
I love the beach.
Say it.
Yeah!
Is this the last mission?
It is not.
No worries.
Actually yeah, there is a lot left to the game.
Not to be too spoilery but...
There is actually quite a bit left of the game.
Going with the tea.
Gone with the tea.
That's kind of what I love about this game though is that it's so much.
There is so much with this game.
We ready?
Are you ready Perky boy?
And for a PSP game, you know.
Alright, let's go!
Solar, thank you so much for the 10 gifted.
Thank you.
Yeah, it doesn't overstay its welcome.
No, the story stays really good.
But, I think it also helps that a lot of the missions are...
There is only one series of missions that really kind of suck.
And if you know, you know.
Don't say anything, obviously.
But...
Those series of missions suck, but everything else is...
Yeah, they are kind of bite-sized, so they are good.
If you know, you know.
And if you don't know, you will know eventually.
So don't worry your pretty little head about it.
Looking for the tea gang!
Greetings from Costa Rica.
Thank you!
Thank you Florent!
A whole year!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
Thank you so much.
The PP flamethrower.
Huey was like, how can we improve this design?
Where is the mammal pod?
Oh, there it is.
It's on his butt.
It's not on his butt, it's on his head.
I
guess we can get the butt though.
Oh, there is one on his butt.
Face me!
Don't like that, don't like that.
Go team go!
It's like the fastest battle ever.
It barely held any...
Anything.
I'm so sad.
Miku are you OK?
I'm getting bossed too, bossed too.
Started the fight, my stream buffered and the fight was over?
No way!
YouTube has been so stinky though lately with the buffering.
Maybe I should like, get out of the way.
He's so stoic, he's so funny.
It's so funny because in these cutscenes he never has any sort of emotion, except just...
Snake stare.
She's gonna hobble away.
Nevermind.
She's gonna zoom away.
Uh-oh.
Where did those come from?
Oh my gosh, shake it off like a doll.
It's the thief's hog, yeah!
Real peace walker.
Bye peace walker!
What do you expect me to do?
This thing is humongous.
It's climbing over hills and mountains.
Go snake, go!
Haunt!
Now we're really fast.
What if we all put our legs together?
All four of us.
Yeah!
Come on!
That's it?
Only 25?
You're starving.
Go!
Nice.
Avoid, avoid, avoid, avoid, avoid, avoid, avoid, avoid, avoid, avoid...
Ok, we're good, we're good.
I'm bashing, I'm bashing.
Ok.
I feel like horses can go over 30 miles per hour.
Is that supposed to mean?
No, I pressed it.
I pressed it, I pressed it.
Oh my god.
My hand!
It's weak from having to do this earlier twice.
That was so close.
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god.
It hurts, it hurts.
No!
It hurts, it hurts, it hurts.
Good job boss.
Thank you.
Oh no!
Why did you think the horse could go upside, like up walls like Spiderman?
Horse!
Just taking a little swim.
Just taking a dip.
He treated the horse like a goat, like a mountain goat.
No!
This isn't Skyrim.
Have you guys ever watched like mountain goat stuff?
Nice job everybody!
Let's go another SRank battle dress.
Let's take it easy.
Guys...
I need my room to the stream chat.
When was the last time you put your bedsheets in the wash?
Yeah.
You're supposed to do it once a week everybody.
Who wants some buns?
About this.
You can wash them.
Basilisco.
Cosibolca.
Speak like a muncher, thank you.
Nicaragua, at the mercy of someone like William Walker again.
Snake, Coldman's going to launch the nuke from that base.
He's targeting MSF.
Based on what Huey's told us, it'll take two more days to prep for launch.
But it looks like there's another reason they picked that date.
What's that?
Tomorrow is day one of a US-Soviet summit in Vladivostok.
The launch is probably connected somehow.
That's right.
They're holding the salt too tight.
You think Coldman's trying to disrupt the negotiations?
Either that or use it as a bargaining chip.
He's still got P.O.S.
too.
At any rate, we're running out of time.
I'll figure something out.
Hot salt man.
I won't rest until I get answers.
Yeah!
We finally got our law, baby.
Nice.
And we've got some more men because they were...
We got quail.
Quail's pretty solid all around.
Antelope too.
Smelt is good for combat.
Nice.
Everything... Our R&D is getting pretty full.
Oh, horse!
We're gonna have to start swapping out some guys to get better things, I think.
We'll save on stuff for now.
Let's keep going with some missions.
Horse reincarnated into a soldier.
It's so sad.
The horse.
Communications Tower.
Okay.
Who wants to also join me for infiltrating the U.S.
Missile Base?
Micmac!
Alright.
I'll take off my T-shirt now.
Wait, we got the new battle suit too.
Yeah!
Look guys.
The battle suit's so cool!
What was that?
What did you just put on?
What did you just...
That was not my snake, I don't think.
Because I didn't change.
It's time?
Wait, is this the... Is this the mission?
Is this the important mission?
Should I bring something bigger?
Ah, the M60 works.
Not yet.
Okay.
Let's go.
The important... It is the important mission.
Just warn me before it's the important mission.
Next one.
Okay, okay.
I knew it was soon.
I'm like, hello, where is it?
The important mission.
Ah!
Let's go baby.
Chapter 4.
Wow, we already got through chapter 3.
The illusion of peace.
I think it will say no Walkman for the important one.
Ah, that makes sense.
That makes sense, right?
Sorry, I'm covering Amanda's face.
Take a horse.
There is only room for one boss.
And one snake.
Wait, I didn't even do it.
Micmac you monster.
Micmac you monster!
I didn't do that.
What?
He was so fast about it too.
Oh my god.
It wasn't me.
I didn't pull any triggers.
The boss wouldn't be allowed to come back home alive.
And she wouldn't be allowed to kill herself.
Her life would be ended by her most beloved disciple.
That was the way that the government wanted it.
That was the mission she was given.
The tainted disgrace will follow her to her grave.
Future generations...
Not for honor, but for you.
In America as a despicable traitor with no sense of honor.
And in Russia as a monster who unleashed a nuclear catastrophe.
She will go down in official history as a war criminal.
That was her final mission.
Snake...
History will never know what she did.
No one will ever learn the truth.
Her story...
Her debriefing...
Will endure only in your heart.
Everything she did, she did for her country.
She sacrificed her life for her country.
Her life and her honor for her native land.
She was a real hero.
She was a true patriot.
Something's not right.
Key card doesn't look too bad.
What do you think?
Gonna need some help.
07s...
0707...
Snake is just our troubled man.
He's so troubled.
He has so much guilt.
Makes him stupid.
He was already stupid.
Nice.
Okay.
They're targeting Mother Base.
Don't you think you should evacuate?
Nah.
Everybody here believes in you, boss.
Alright, fine then.
I've kind of gotten attached to the place myself.
Me too!
They've been taken to safety.
We can't involve them in this any further.
Good.
They've got their own cause to fight for.
And Snake...
Don't forget the bad guys have got P.O.S.
I won't.
We're prepping a few backup units.
Don't let them launch, Snake.
We're counting on you.
No spoilers
you guys!
There's people in chat that have not played the game.
Please no spoilers.
Thank you.
Holy crack!
Wow!
Get this...
Get this girl in...
Oh my gosh!
A Magic the Gathering room!
Her crack...
is totally out!
Actually, I'm gonna have this smoke grenade.
What the hell?
This is messed up.
Get back!
Why would you do this to me?
Oh, I see him.
Hold on, I'll get this guy.
Holy...
Oh shoot.
No, don't say anything.
No, you didn't say anything.
Oh shoot.
No, I messed up!
Dang it.
Let's get this guy...secretly.
Oh, you can't see me though.
You stupid.
Oh, my bad.
Why are you so smart?
I messed up.
Mic Mac, I messed up my aim.
The stealth messed up my aim.
Nice.
I'm gonna be brave too.
Tick-a-dink, tick-a-dink, tick-a-dink, tick-a-dink.
All clear!
That's so smart.
They're so dumb.
Can I get this thing?
You think I should?
Oh my god, he's so close.
But they'll hear it, no?
Nobody even heard a thing.
Oh, they definitely heard a thing.
Who's down there anyway?
Don't worry about them.
They're probably babies.
Oh, I hear somebody.
Probably from up there.
Stop making me invisible, it's weird.
Oh, I didn't mean to...
What are you doing?
Why'd you do that?
No!
There we go.
I want to join you!
OK
He wants to join.
That was kinda loud.
Oh, you got him.
Nice.
Sneak in.
Sneak out.
How do we get up from here?
Oh, here.
Oh my gosh.
That was quiet.
Ah, nice and quiet.
They don't.
They're stupid.
Yeah, what stealth?
We don't need stealth.
McMahon kinda cheeked up.
This one is...
Oh yeah, I remember this.
Look at you.
I don't get to do such fancy stuff.
What is...
Prisoner.
Oh, hello.
Oh gosh, you scared me.
You scared me McMahon.
Oh my gosh.
You scared me like nothing else.
Oh my gosh, this man.
Start talking.
Oh he also wants to join.
Wait, can I...oh shoot.
You want to join us?
You want to join?
Let him in.
We just gotta open this door, no?
What you say?
Come on.
Oh wait.
Oh sorry, my bad.
Hello?
Don't I just gotta open this?
Ouch!
What?
Isn't it that you have to do that here?
Not this door?
Oh, where was it?
It is literally...how do I open it again?
I don't remember.
Ok, I'm following you.
I thought we had to go into the big tunnel, no?
Where is it?
Nobody.
No!
Oh wait, this is the goal.
Wait, I was...
I think I'm all backwards.
Sorry guys.
The tunnel is later.
Oh, I'm all backwards right now you guys.
I'm so sorry.
I was misremembering.
Oopsie!
I'll find specimens over here.
Oh yeah!
Ah!
Please!
There we go.
Bye!
He's mine!
CQC baby!
What is going on down there?
Get his butt!
You could have warned me about that.
Oh, please.
Please.
My eyes!
Ok!
Oh, shoot.
Gosh, I...
I'm so sorry.
I didn't notice.
Bring me back to life!
I'm sorry.
I didn't notice that I was...
That I... I'm sorry.
I'll quit my rations.
Oh, but I gotta get this guy home.
I'm sorry.
I didn't notice.
I didn't...
This guy is just like chillin' in the mud.
He's gonna fall asleep!
Boss?
Boss!
Yeah, we got saved by this fine piece of art.
Mmhm.
Ah yeah!
The nice view, I know, right?
Eyes.
Eyes!
Snake!
Can you hear me?
Si, I can hear you.
Where are you?
I'm not sure.
I don't recognize it.
What about Coldman?
He just left for the control tower.
Said something about entering the final data.
That doesn't seem...
What is the matter?
That doesn't seem good.
Uh-oh.
Ah, the doubles.
Easy peasy.
What is going on?
I love this picture.
I'm coming, Paz.
Do not worry about me.
I am an angel of peace.
I will be watching over you.
I love her so much!
My sweet angel of peace!
I love Paz so much.
Wow, I got a lot of heroism.
Let's go!
Good job team!
CQC master!
We got some guys.
We got some prisoners.
Do you love her so much?
Why don't you marry her?
I would if I could.
I absolutely would.
I would marry Paz.
Pacifica Ocean!
Give me a smelt again.
This guy sucks.
Let's see.
Llama.
Llama, our little engineer.
Good morning Minto.
I've been told you recruited my wife Firefly.
I hope she's doing good work at Mother Base.
She kind of sucks, but that's okay.
And Peefowl and Iguana.
Not to be mistaken for the elusive Sea Iguana.
Oh my gosh, pig sucks.
Sockeye Salmon.
Dove is pretty good.
We got to start weaning out the weenies of the R&D.
Okay!
This next mission is important everybody.
And I would like to enjoy the moment.
So, maybe don't take out the helicopter too quickly.
Okay!
If you are the one who joins.
And Drinkles thank you so much for the 20 gifts.
Thank you!
Space Iguana.
So...yeah, just...yeah.
Just...yeah, be support.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay!
I love Kaz's Call of Duty mic.
Yeah.
Go a little bit slower than you usually would in this one.
Okay.
Dull Bracelet.
Welcome, welcome.
I think...I think actually what I have is pretty good.
Because I have the M60.
Which I can use.
Yeah, yeah.
I think it should be okay.
Alrighty.
Alrighty, alrighty.
Yeah, no Walkman.
No Walkman.
Let's...Oh!
Oh!
I didn't realize I even had it.
Oops.
I had the Walkman!
Me!
Oopsie.
It's okay.
We took it out.
Don't run.
Don't walk, man.
What if I...What if I skip, man?
What if I crawl, man?
Yeah.
Die hard, man.
No run, man.
The suit!
Suit!
You are well dressed for the occasion, sir.
Oh my goodness.
East of...
Those guys are on the lookout.
He doesn't even care.
Wait, how did he not care?
Is he stupid?
Are you dumb?
Get him walking into the wall.
Don't put me to sleep.
Oh gosh, a thing.
Stupid.
I'm just gonna take these guys out.
Oh, that's not what I meant to do.
Oh, please.
Hello, sir.
Sniper!
Can I get him?
Nice!
Nice headshot.
I think his head is behind the thing.
Oh, that was my fault.
I didn't notice.
Nice.
Good job, team.
The music is so cool, right?
Oh, there's two of them.
My aim.
My bad.
Yes!
Good job.
Good job, team.
They take a long time to fall asleep, don't they?
Now he's asleep.
He said from where we came from, right?
You ready?
You ready, bracelet?
He feels asleep.
From what sea it came.
Oh it's open now.
What do you know?
Who is shooting at me?
What the hell was that?
Where did that come from?
Hey you!
You son of
a...
The gate is this way.
Oh my gosh!
Wait!
OK.
We are OK.
I said stay down!
I'm just going for him.
Stay down!
What did I just hear?
Can I take a sleep for a second?
Sleep, sleep, sleep.
Yawn, yawn, yawn.
Yawn, yawn.
Yes, a little rest.
Just a little nap.
Just like the rest of these guys.
Tank it up.
Let's go!
Little mid-battle siesta.
Exactly.
Ya, that's what they do in Europe, you know.
Everybody says... Oh, hold on.
It's tea time.
That is the tea alarm sounding.
I hate these guys.
Oh nice job.
Wow.
What do you mean make something to conceal myself?
Oh shoot, I did the wrong thing.
Ya!
What you got?
Like a cardboard box?
I do have something of the sort.
Oh wait, that thing is still up.
What are you shooting at?
I could have sworn I equipped the rescue box, but I don't think I did.
Because I'm silly.
Holy cow!
Oh my gosh, I equipped the ration just at the right time.
You!
Don't.
Do not fire that.
In front of my face.
No!
Bracelet!
I got you!
Hold on.
I will have you.
In a second.
What?
Europe.
Europe buddy.
Watch out behind you!
Behind you!
I'm gonna take a siesta.
Siesta.
I'm out of rations, you're right.
Are we gonna be OK?
Should we take him?
Oh.
No.
I got some S curry.
Oh sorry, my bad.
I was gonna get this guy.
Do you have enough stuff?
Grab your things!
Ouch!
Wait, do I have... I don't.
I didn't bring it.
I didn't bring my own strike thing.
Or whatever.
I'm gonna take that.
Alright, come on!
Oh wait, does he have anything?
I missed my chance.
Wait.
OK, that's fine.
Let's just go.
That could have been cleaner.
That could have been cleaner maybe.
A little bit better.
Run for it!
Run!
Don't die on me!
You son of a bitch.
I'm using the action button!
Wait.
Action.
Action button?
What?
Where's the action button?
Oh, we're already through it.
We're already through it, guys.
It's like the wrong thing.
What a dumbo.
Hives are such a drama queen.
Heliport time!
OK.
A bit late on the advice.
He stressed me out.
Let's get to top health and be in tip-top shape.
We're almost there.
So close.
We're safe.
We're gonna be all good.
Alrighty.
Action button.
I'm sick of the action, guys.
I just want to lay here and become one with the earth.
I want to become a worm!
OK, I'm good.
Let's go.
Maybe.
Close.
Almost.
Yes.
Watch out for the gunship.
Oh yes.
Oh my god.
Yes, this is 100%.
I'm getting to the thing.
There's nowhere to run.
You've got to take those guys down.
That was close.
Aim.
Don't go.
Violence!
No!
I don't need!
Violence!
What do you mean?
OK.
Violence!
Where's the chopper?
Oh my god, Kaz.
Give me a second.
I was just looking.
How am I supposed to take care of a chopper if I can't go outside, Kaz?
Are you OK?
You're fine.
Go!
Ow.
Come on.
What's
that?
Nice.
Where did he go?
There he is.
Oh, I missed.
We'll
wait for the chorus to pick up.
Peace!
I'm
almost out of ammo!
I'm out of ammo!
Bracelet!
You can do it!
Oh my gosh, we got it twice.
Let's go.
I'll take him.
I'll take him home.
Peace.
My bad.
Hey!
Watch out!
You're money hungry.
You're hungry.
You're too hungry for violence.
I'll take you home too.
I'll save you!
Let's go.
I have a support!
So beautiful.
I love this game.
For peace!
Pause!
Oh my god.
Peak incoming, you guys.
Peak incoming.
Retaliate.
This is so messed up.
This is so backwards.
He is so stupid.
We have reverse engineered the false data so that she'll inevitably end up choosing the Caribbean Sea as her target.
You're really gonna do it, aren't you?
Know this.
Peace Walker's retaliation will be the first and last of the Cold War.
It is the only way we will ever come close to achieving true peace.
What?
All that is left is to enter the cold.
No!
You're late.
Uh oh.
No way.
We have a double crosser in our boots.
Oh my god.
Professor...what's his name?
Galvez?
Yeah, I only know him as a doorknob.
The world will burn with anti-American sentiment.
Communism will spread across Latin America unchecked.
Let the age of deterrence be undone by the deterrent itself.
Such is the Kremlin's plan.
You son of a bitch!
Thanks for letting me join the mission.
You...
No!
You were so great.
Thank you for joining.
I am Vladimir Zadornov.
ZADORNOV!
The doorknob!
No!
Paz, don't do it.
Or you could.
Whatever.
I'm sorry.
This guy is such a weenie.
The absolute weenie.
Oof.
Ouchie ouch.
Oof my bones.
Oof.
Ouchie ouch my bones.
Your part in this isn't done.
I need you to enter the code.
Doctor, the target is now Cuba.
Please make the necessary modifications.
And don't even think of resisting.
I'll crush you, but only after I crush your beloved first.
So rude.
No!
Not that!
Cuba is now the retaliation target.
Very well.
Good.
It is done.
As for you, big boss... I've been watching you all along.
You've performed beyond even my highest expectations.
A true commandante.
What are you talking about?
Yeah, I'm good at the game.
Why do you think I summoned you to Costa Rica?
Had you made contact with the Sandinistas?
A true intelligence operative never gets his hands dirty.
Need a revolution?
Manipulate the locals into doing it for you.
Commandante?
I mean Amanda and the Sandinistas.
You've done well.
You took a ragtag band of gorillas, children, and shaped them into a full-fledged formidable army.
My boss is good at that.
Taking children and making them into an army.
Wait, is this foreshadowing?
None other.
A hero who, gunned down by the CIA, becomes a legendary icon.
The Sandinistas will rise up in revenge, overthrowing the pro-American regime and wresting Nicaragua from U.S.
hands.
And the nuclear strike on Cuba, naturally, will be the last straw.
Mammal pod data entry is complete.
Dead at age 39.
Just like El Che.
Ironic, isn't it?
A legend is merely fiction.
You'll die as the boss did, and become as did she, an eternal fraud.
Go!
Yeah!
We'll win!
Freeze!
You dare point your gun at a comrade?
We will not be pawns of the KGB.
We will win our own victory!
Hasta la victoria siempre!
Amanda!
Vic, boss!
We're home!
Look!
We're back in Nica!
We did it, Amanda!
I mean...
Comandante!
Boss, you hurt.
Comandante?
Vic, boss!
You're regular Joan of Arc.
Nonsense.
You're the hero here.
You saved my life.
You're the heroes here.
Vic, boss!
I never figured you for a softie, Snake.
Thanks.
It's good to see you.
Ahhhhhhhhh Vic, boss!
Vic, boss!
Boss can stay with us until she's back on her feet.
And the professor?
We'll find him a nice, comfy cell.
Goldman has lost a lot of blood.
He may not make it...
Where is Amanda?
Back with her compa.
She will catch up later.
And nobody was sad about that.
I wanted to know how she really felt.
How it really ended.
The boss is dead.
No, she's alive.
Some truths are better left buried.
You don't mean that.
Be honest, you want to know too, don't you?
Whether what she saw and heard at the end was the truth.
She'll tell us.
I know she will.
Thank you for stopping them.
And I'm sorry.
I can't imagine how it hurt.
I'll live.
I'm used to shark therapy.
You are?
Strange love is a trucker.
I miss the heaven's divide, unfortunately.
Let's go meet her, shall we?
Get in.
Boss.
Don't pick up a gun unless you know how to use it.
She didn't.
It wasn't her fault.
Aiming a weapon alone doesn't make it a deterrent.
Cause!
She was forced to.
Shut up.
You're the angel of peace.
Leave the guns to us.
My baby.
Don't cry, little princess.
That was our agreement, remember?
The army is leaving Costa Rica now.
The mission is complete.
Paz?
I love this picture too.
Thank you.
I love you so much.
Also, why did we not...
Oh my god, this stupid...
This is the dumbest part, I think, of the whole game.
Somebody stop him!
Somebody do something!
That's so stupid!
Oh my god!
Somebody do something!
What?
The guy is supposed to be dead.
He is such a cockroach.
Oh my god.
One last gacha pull.
I thought you had him.
No, I thought you had him.
Uh oh.
The milk signal.
Signal.
I didn't even catch that.
Oh my god.
No!
Lord B.B.
and John.
No, it's no rap.
They track Santa Claus.
This guy is so stupid!
This guy is so dumb.
No one among them has the courage to push the button.
No one willing to enter history as the great destroyer.
In the end, it's not their lives that people value most.
It's their reputations.
The bureaucrats in Washington may not be able to retaliate.
He is so stupid.
They made a milk signal.
I am ready for death.
Why is he making that face?
You gotta...
You gotta break the eggs to make an omelette.
Right?
Are you insane?
You think it will end there?
You're about to unleash all out nuclear war.
I need to find out what's going on at NORAD.
Mammals got a connection to NORAD.
We can monitor it with the right equipment.
I've got you covered.
Huey!
Huey doing something good for once.
I've got NORAD on the line.
Sir, we're tracking unidentified targets.
Current Apogee 20 degrees.
No, here we go!
He's been awfully quiet this whole time, hasn't he?
I've contacted the president.
Coverall is not responding.
Reporting system checks out.
No corresponding natural signatures.
Data is assessed as reliable.
Cut the data transmission.
We can't say for sure Washington isn't going to retaliate.
The only one who knows the abort code is me.
This guy sucks so much.
I die and no one can turn it off.
Even if they do strike back, I'll already be dead.
I can only pray that my theory... my peace... is proven right.
Go to DEFCON 3.
Get Zack on the throne.
This is Crystal Palace.
Stand by for an emergency meeting.
They're at DEFCON 3.
The false data and the nukes are both coming from the same source.
We have to stop Peace Walker.
The only way is to destroy him.
She's entered launch mode.
Peace Walker has rendered her judgment.
The target is Cuba.
You guys ready?
Big mission!
Big mission.
P killed him.
I thought of P and died.
Maybe that's why it happened to you guys.
Peace Walker!
Peace Crawler.
He peaced out.
He's such a stinky guy.
It's calculating ballistic trajectory.
Once that's finished, it's all over.
Snake, you've got to destroy the platform.
In the next episode!
Yeah!
You guys ready for a big bang finale?
Launching SMILE!
We didn't do so hot in that one, but that's OK!
Dull Bracelet, you were great!
You were so awesome.
Thank you!
Thanks for also letting the song play.
You did perfect.
You did everything so well.
Thank you!
It was awesome.
It felt so good.
Let's sort our men again and then we'll go into the last mission.
Oh yeah, that's the guy that got rhinoceros.
We took a couple.
Let's see.
Horse!
Wow!
Horses are really good in R&D.
Let's see.
Let's get...wait.
We will replace horse with another horse.
So we finish today?
You'll see.
We replace one Hans with another Hans.
I think this guy can actually like it.
I think we can actually discharge him.
So scary.
Oh whoops, my bad.
Nice!
You're fired.
Let's see.
Marine Iguana.
You're not very good either.
Sorry.
You're fired.
Oh, I keep doing that.
Sorry, my bad.
We want better weapons and things.
We're picky now everybody.
Mother Base is only so big.
We need all the good stuff that we can get.
Well team.
It's been an honor fighting with you all.
Peace Walker battle number two.
Snake, don't let it launch the nuke.
I feel like Kaz has said this like 50 different times.
Don't let Peace Walker launch the nuke.
And I am creating the room now.
Arisaka.
Rooks.
And Silver Hida.
Welcome.
Wow we are international today.
Let's go.
And as you know...
For any fight...
Exactly!
We got... Oh see I have the rescue box.
What is that one?
I missed it.
What was that?
Killing with the team.
We got it.
Kazuhira.
Oh my god.
Thank you.
Chop, grenade, supply.
This is all pretty standard.
Let me know when you guys are ready.
I don't like pressing start mission until everyone is ready because it gives a little countdown.
What does Kazuhira mean in Japanese again?
We haven't heard Kaz say anything about Japan today.
It's a little disappointing.
What are we saying about Huey?
Do you think when they fire people at mother base they send them off in a little...
Why would you say that?
Sorry behind there it goes.
I must time you out.
Oh wait.
It won't let me.
Why won't it let me?
YouTube is bugging out.
Not cool.
Oh no.
Wait, is that me?
Wait, was that my fault?
I'm so sorry.
Hold on.
Not cool.
OK, let me try again.
Sorry, I thought we already played five.
Not on my channel.
If it's not on my channel, don't say spoilers about it.
I think it's the best...
I got twin snake gummy snacks.
Oh my god, those are so good.
I love those.
I love, love, love those.
OK.
Wait, I'm prepped.
Let's go.
I'm so sorry about everybody who didn't make it in before.
I'm so sorry.
I think there was a connection issue.
Hopefully not this time.
Thank you for the 20 gift invite.
There it goes.
It's OK.
I, you know, obviously I know...
the stuff, but I try to be, I try to be fair for anybody who's watching this series for the first time.
Which there is a good number of people, so...
Onigiri!
Giri got gifted.
That's so funny.
Giri!
Let's go team!
And she's awake everybody!
I don't know when she'll start moving, so...
Ouch!
Help, help, help.
Oh yeah, does she start running here?
Weee!
Face me!
Oh my gosh, I was so close.
Watch out!
Rooks!
I got you!
Oh you got him.
Good, good, good.
She's launching S-Mines you guys.
Do you think she's launching S-Mines?
Rooks!
Oh my gosh, she's so cool.
I love Peace Walker.
She's so cool.
Oh shoot.
Wow.
Sorry, my finger totally slipped.
We're OK.
We're OK team.
Go team!
Oh no!
Oh no, no, no, no!
Oh, not strike.
Supply.
Rooks are you OK?
Why did I get a grenade?
Oh I guess because the rocket's off.
Go team!
Oh.
Nice.
That was clean.
Launching S-Mines.
Wait.
Am I out?
I'm out.
I don't know if that hit her or not.
Hey!
Hey, where's she going?
Peace Walker.
Oh my god, don't say that.
Stop blurting on the battlefield.
Oh, I missed.
You know what, while we're waiting for her to come back...
No,
no, no!
Is she about to charge?
Come on snake, get up!
That was pretty good.
She's targeting me you guys.
She's obsessed with me.
Are you obsessed with me?
This car?
Oh my god!
I'm stuck!
You guys, I can't see shit!
That was so bad.
That was like the worst possible scenario.
Face me!
Oh shit!
Oh damn!
Oh my god, I almost died.
Oh my god, that took out two rations.
That's crazy.
Good job!
Good job team!
That one final hit watching that go...
Was so good.
Good job team!
Good job!
Here it comes.
One of my favorite parts of the game.
I'm not ready.
Maybe I'm just old.
Nah, Rooks is great.
Feels incoming you guys.
How's NORAD?
That fight literally took me hours to finish.
No, it's because we have a team of four.
Of course.
By yourself it's so difficult.
What the?
What?
Wait, what?
What's happening?
Wait, what is this?
Let me check my table.
Ok.
That was weird.
What?
Or maybe one of the others, or maybe...
No!
Of course he did, stupid dummy.
Dumb.
But the speech bubble said the Pentagon.
Then who?
Oh my god.
When will my day come that Big Boss calls me...
Smart dumb man.
Maybe for your birthday.
Nah.
Oh,
hey all Raiders.
Thank you for the raid.
This is kind of spoilers for Metal Gear Peace Walker, so...
Yes.
He held a grudge for that forever.
Only a handful of people would know.
Because he's stanky.
Trust me.
Everything.
Yay, all is good.
When we meet again, I hope you'll shake my hand.
What a fanboy.
All is not good.
Butterfly in the sky.
She's calling to you.
Oh yeah,
we lost somebody.
There's only three now.
Oh no, who did we lose?
Maybe my T-shirt.
Boss.
All is good.
The ten minutes.
I'm working on it.
The pedals.
It's so HAL.
Her pain sounds are so sad.
Yeah, very HAL.
It won't be a stylish marriage.
I can't remember.
The way you look.
I cannot see.
She can't even remember Pi anymore.
Is this familiar?
Don't say it.
Don't say his name.
No!
He's got so much room in his pants.
It hurts.
It stopped.
The data uplink is bypassing the mammal pod.
Put down the gun.
Come to your senses, man.
The fate of the world, the fate of the earth is at stake here.
Why?
I don't understand.
Answer me.
Tell me why.
Answer me!
I hate her.
Six minutes remaining.
Wait.
Authority rests with me now.
I'm ordering a retaliation.
No, don't.
It's the end of us all.
Who gives a damn?
I'm not gonna sit here and die like a dog.
If the Russians are gonna kill my family, destroy my country, I'm taking them with me.
You see now, Chairman.
Deterrence is just a fool's dream.
No!
Why?
Why won't it stop?
Our peace.
Sometimes the body continues to live even after the brain is damaged.
The boss AI isn't doing this.
I think it's something rather more primitive.
You created a monster.
Reptile has taken up mammal's dying wish.
No.
Stop it.
Don't just sit there.
Stop it!
Goldman was so wrong.
I know.
What a dummy, idiot, stupid head.
Lizard.
Good job team.
What did we lose?
Oh, it was like the one that... What was your name?
I'm sorry.
Exceeding 250 co-ops.
Nice.
Yeah, Leo.
Thank you.
Leo, I hope you're okay.
Sadness happening soon.
Oh, I meant to go to the mission select.
My bad.
We got some more guys.
Cod, Shrew and Sparrow.
Wow, you're good at combat.
They're all good at combat.
Take you.
He's dead.
He died in combat.
Peace Walker Battle 3!
See buddy, you can get in again.
If you did the last Peace Walker fight though, try to...
Wait.
If you did the last Peace Walker fight, maybe give someone else a chance.
Thank you.
If someone joins.
There we go!
Thank you guys.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Alright team.
Let's go baby.
Mission prep.
Going with the team.
Survival?
That doesn't sound like a t-shirt to me.
That's more like it.
I'm ready when you guys are.
Going with the team.
Thank you guys for being so gracious.
You guys gave up your spots so fast.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
I really appreciate it.
Alright, Unstoppable, Gibsonator and Brighty.
Let's go into battle!
No connection error please.
Start?
I click start the menu?
I click start mission.
I
think maybe someone had a connection issue.
Let's try again.
Brighty in.
Arisaka in.
Gibsonator in.
Alright, let's try again.
Let's try again.
I'm scared.
Gibsonator, is it you?
Is it because you are so far away?
We made it!
WSF!
It worked baby.
Alright.
We got this team!
No nuclear war for us today!
Oh my god, the car's outfit!
Can I look at you real quick?
I didn't see it before.
Huey never shows up on the loading screen.
Wait, wait, wait.
Come here, come here Arisaka.
Come here, come here.
You look so good.
I love it.
A lot of explosions now.
Oh I thought I clicked reload.
Get
my goose stomp out.
Reloading too fast for the game.
I guess it really doesn't matter if we shoot the mammal pod or not.
Maybe we gotta shoot the brain.
Shoot the other one.
Good job team!
Thank you.
Doing the Jackal pose.
That's what I'm saying.
How
are you guys?
Are you guys having fun?
I tried to run into you guys.
OK.
Well, good fight.
Good fight everybody.
That's the time.
Peace!
Don't do it Miku!
Miku is possessed.
Oh no.
Vocaloid pod.
My heart.
A loading screen.
That voice.
What?
What's going on?
That song.
Is that you?
How in love?
The culture is happening.
A ghost in machine?
She's drowning herself to stop the transmission.
Look!
It's functional compensation.
When the human brain is damaged, sometimes it recovers over time.
Other parts of the brain take over the functions of the damaged parts.
Mammal and reptile were patterned after different parts of the human brain.
When those parts were assembled together into one, they must have become capable of functional compensation.
Stop putting science to it Huey.
It's love.
It's magic.
It's the boss' will for peace.
The song.
It's clearly not thinking rationally.
It's not using its head.
It's using its heart.
This is the fate she chose for herself.
The boss' innocence has been proven.
Do you hear it Snake?
Do you hear the boss' song?
You saw it, didn't you?
When you went to space.
That there's beauty outside of battle.
At last, I understand.
In the end, it was you who put down your gun.
And chose instead to sing.
They can all hear you.
I know they can.
And your will shall surely live on.
That's what you wanted.
So much that you gave up everything you had.
But you couldn't achieve it.
Isn't that right?
And still, all you can do is sing.
There's no peace to be found anywhere.
And so, we can only keep on hoping.
Hoping for the illusion we call peace.
Peace.
That's too good.
Oh my god.
Look, and now there's peace.
In time, all standing armies must be totally abolished.
Immanuel Kant.
Perpetual... What did I say?
I don't know.
Perpetual peace.
Thank you.
Sing a song.
This song makes me cry.
To last your whole life long.
Don't worry that it's not good enough for anyone else to hear.
Just sing.
Sing a song.
Just sing a song.
There's of course an after bit.
Just sing.
Sing a song.
So good.
Such a good ending for the boss, I suppose.
Where are my backup singers at?
So, so good.
He was like, change that stinking radio.
Dedicated in loving memory of Project Ito.
Okay.
The US and the Soviet Union agreed on a framework of assault to the treaty limits the number of bombs.
Among that number, MIRVs are restricted to 1320.
The former Prime Minister of Japan received a Nobel Peace Prize for non-nuclear principles.
Nicaragua takes sausages.
Oh no, that's not good.
The former President of Costa Rica admits to collaborating with the CIA.
Saigon reunites North and South Vietnam.
The Soviet Union and the US complete a peaceful journey.
Peace, peace, peace.
Huey becomes a father.
He names his son Hal.
Gorbachev becomes a power.
Berlin Wall falls.
Germany is reunified the following year.
Costa Rican government persuades Panama to abolish its military.
Amongst...
To be continued in Chapter 5.
Oh my gosh, I saw a video of Lori Allen yesterday.
Except it wasn't her talking about Metal Gear.
It was her talking as Pearl from Spongebob.
I was like, it's so funny.
When she just talks normally, she sounds so much like the boss.
My original save was on the PS3.
It was so fun replaying this alongside with you.
My new Zeke is so far from being done.
Yeah, it takes a long time to complete it.
I will reach out to you.
And leave this all behind.
When heavens divide.
So good.
So, so, so good.
I love this game.
I love this game so much.
It's so stupid.
It's so beautiful at the same time.
When heavens divide.
I will see the choices within my hands.
How can we ever protect and fight with our tiny souls?
Let me shine like the sun through the doubts and fear.
Do you feel the storm approach as the end draws near?
When heavens divide.
Time will come to softly lay me down.
I can see a face that I long to see.
Vocaloid!
Miku!
Leaving a trace for love to find a way.
When heavens divide.
Time...
The lyrics have such a different meaning.
Like, they mean so much more after you play this game, you know?
Like, it's just...
It's like, Snake Eater is the boss talking to Snake.
And this song is Snake talking to the boss.
It's just...
The blood of my desire.
The very last time.
My name scorched into the sky.
When heavens divide.
I will see the choices within my hands.
How can we ever protect and fight with our tiny souls?
Let me shine like the sun through the doubts and fear.
Do you feel the storm approach as the end draws near?
When heavens divide.
Time will come to softly lay me down.
Then I can see a face that I long to see.
And for you, only you, I would give anything.
Leaving a trace for love to find the way.
When heavens divide.
It's a heart-wrenching line.
I know.
And for you,
only you, I would give anything.
To find the way.
When heavens divide.
So good.
So good, so good.
We're waiting for the end of credits.
UNIQLO!
07, 07, 07.
And then, oh my god.
The theme song of this game is just too good too.
Oh, Space Odyssey.
Sing!
We haven't heard that song yet.
These are all the Walkman songs.
So good.
I remember hearing this song at the...
Oh my god, I heard this song at the Metal Gear Orchestra.
And I was literally just a puddle on the ground.
And my tears were like, never ending.
My whole face was wet with how much I was crying.
It was so beautiful.
I'm so happy I could go.
Ok, a little bit more.
I remember that.
Yes, but also...
She betrayed me, Kaz.
She what?
In the end.
She put down her gun.
And when she did, she rejected her entire life up to that point.
Including me.
What do you mean?
In giving up her life, she abandoned everything she was as a soldier.
And you consider that betrayal?
I won't make the same choice as her.
My future is going to be different.
Snake.
Yeah, that's right.
Here he is.
From now on, call me Big Boss.
Yeah!
Big Boss!
Yellow!
Wait one second.
I think my thing is all broken.
There we go.
Tuxedo!
We got the illusion of peace.
All signs are her scholarship came from the KGB too.
Even if they let him go, she's not going to be seeing any more money.
It wouldn't have been much anyway.
So, I was wondering...
Let my girl get an education!
What about letting her stay here for a while?
What does she think?
The doorknob.
She says she wants to help out.
It would only be temporary.
She's still in shock.
Right now, no one understands her better than we do.
Okay.
But Kaz...
Sorry, I didn't realize it was so loud.
Don't take your eyes off her.
What do you mean?
It won't be easy getting used to this kind of life.
I know, Snake.
I'm not trying to turn her into one of us.
Yay, pause!
You need to talk to her yourself later.
Okay.
And...
Doctor Strangelove wants to come too.
Yay, Strangelove!
Well, she's out of a job now.
And she has a problem returning to England.
You can talk to her about it.
Anyway, you don't need me to tell you how good she'd be for R&D.
Yippee!
I love pause.
Cecile, the girl who is never seen...
Never heard from again.
Oh, this guy is about to be the biggest thorn in our side, everybody.
This guy is about to be...
A real stink.
Do we have to put her in there with Huey?
Black Seabream...
I'm sorry, you're no longer needed.
You're fired.
What about pause?
Where would she go?
Food, of course.
To the mess hall.
And to R&D.
You're fired.
But guys, but Minto, what are you still worrying about?
Did you not beat the game?
Why are you still...
Why are you still trying to get more stuff?
Well, we have extra ops, of course.
Actually, there is...
Cancel.
Let's...
The game is over.
Stop playing.
Never be game over.
Like date with Paz.
Of course.
My first exposure to Metal Gear was seeing that part of Peace Walker.
And I could tell it was something special.
I'm glad I got to see it all the way through with you this time.
Thank you, Minto.
Next!
Thank you for the pig!
No, no, no, no, no.
Cancel, cancel, cancel.
Here we go.
Can't it be her last words?
Basically follow your orders and do your job like a soldier.
What do you mean?
What are you missing?
Triple skull rating.
I don't know if you guys have noticed, but the skulls on the side are the difficulty level.
Oh my god.
Wait, I don't think I'm ready for this.
I don't think I'm...
Sorry.
I'm okay.
Alright, Snake, we gotta get you smelling nice.
Okay, I'm okay.
I'm okay.
I'm okay, I'm okay.
Everybody, it's our date.
It's time for our date with Buzz!
Look at the way he stares.
Look at her pretty little face.
Okay.
Alright, play it cool, play it cool, Snake.
Play it cool, play it cool, Snake.
Hello, Paws.
Maybe not these.
Rupee?
Oh, I didn't customize my things.
No,
now we're pulling out.
What?
Let's use our cologne.
I can't use my cologne!
Oh my god.
She likes it.
Yeah!
What are you talking about?
Oh, she doesn't like that one.
Yeah!
Oh, sorry.
Sorry.
Let's equip.
Camera!
Can I get a nice one of you in the sunset?
Turn around.
Turn around, Paws.
Paws!
Paws, look here, Paws.
She's so cute.
Wait, how do I... Can I zoom?
Oh, sorry.
Sorry.
You are going to take a picture of me?
Yeah, yeah.
Look how cute she is.
Look how cute she is!
Oh, sorry.
Sorry.
No, no, no, no.
I'm messing it up.
Go!
I'm not impressing her anymore.
Peace!
She has nothing to say about that one.
I wouldn't either, to be honest.
She's like, what the hell are you talking about?
Well, I don't think we're gonna get so far in this one, you guys.
But, she might meow back if you try it again.
Hey, can you... Can you...
Alright, here we go, guys.
You are going to take a picture of me?
Why am I so big?
Oh my gosh, here we go.
Oh my god.
I'm gonna do the photographer thing where you get on the ground, you know?
Oh, but I have to step back.
Okay, there we go.
There we go.
Yeah, keep twirling.
Keep twirling.
You are so cute.
Yes!
I'm getting your best angles.
What's wrong with me?
Oh, I'm running into the scarecrow.
Look how cute she was running up to me!
Oh my god.
She's such...
She's such a natural.
Would you like to listen to some music?
How do I... Actually, how do I scroll through it?
No, no, no.
Stop.
How do I scroll through it?
Eh?
D-pad?
No, D-pad is not working.
X and B?
No, let's play and...
Well, maybe Y and A.
Maybe I'm...
No, those are blacked out, so no.
You have to upgrade to unlock scrolling?
No way!
It's so cheap.
Okay, next time, pause.
Next time, we'll listen to some really great tunes.
Oh, my bad.
Sorry.
Needed items.
Something Paz would like.
Does she like...
Curry?
Do you like this?
Maybe closer to her.
No!
I'm sorry!
You want the curry?
Curry!
You're the one running up to me.
Okay, let's just try it.
Room for one more?
We have to have other things that Paz likes.
I have to...
I didn't equip...
Huey jumpscare.
Oh my god.
Glad to hear it.
That was cool.
Okay!
Don't do that.
I think that would be...
pretty bad.
I think that wouldn't be so great.
I think this is already a bad idea to begin with.
And now...
we have...
Metal Gear!
Well, I have like...
Look!
Oh wait.
Hold on.
Look!
Nothing there.
This is... What's that one story?
About the guy that swindles the king into buying invisible clothes and he's just naked?
Metal Gear... That's literally what's happening right here.
Our main parts... We got like nothing.
We have nothing, you guys.
Wait?
No...
Nothing.
Emperor's new clothes.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
Yeah, mine has stealth camo.
I'm so far advanced.
Sorry, I know.
It's like so, so cool, right?
Wait, I'm gonna upgrade the Walkman.
We have so much GMP now.
Yeah.
Nothing here.
Oh my gosh, wasn't the...
Wasn't the date so great?
Now guys, there is one last thing I wanna do.
Before we end for today.
I don't think I have it though.
Oh, there it is.
The Snake Gear Retrieval.
The one thing I wanted to do...
This... Wait.
First of all, I'm just gonna say...
It's not a spoiler, but...
Do you guys remember what I have to... If anybody has played this game...
Do you remember what I have to do to get the spooky mission?
Spooky mission?
You guys, stop it.
I already have plans for the Monster Hunter.
I'm gonna
look it up.
I'm gonna look it up.
What do I have to do?
Spooky mission.
How do I get it?
Maybe I need to do more extra.
Maybe.
I might have to finish the earlier ones.
OK, maybe.
Now the unlock order.
OK.
We'll do other missions.
Wait.
No, no, no.
Then I'm just gonna...
I'm not gonna do this.
No, we're not.
I'm just going into the briefing files.
Chica...
Is it this one or the Legend?
Chica... Let's do the Isle first.
Is it the Uma one?
I remember reading that.
OK, there's a couple that I don't want to watch anymore.
It's been an honor by your side.
Thank you!
Thank you so much!
Talking cat, huh?
2001 Space Odyssey.
I'm looking for it.
I might have to unlock it.
Thank you!
It was a mistake.
Canonically believes in Santa Claus and I'm just obsessed with that fact.
OK.
So wait, so extra ops... What was it?
29?
Wait...
Chiquita, what was it again?
Scrolling, I'm scrolling, I'm scrolling, I'm scrolling, I'm scrolling, I'm scrolling, I'm scrolling, I'm scrolling...
Yep, OK.
Oh, only I can do this one.
No!
How lonely.
Single player only.
It's 29.
OK.
Single player only.
So lonely.
OK, I have C4 already.
OK.
Actually, before we go, before I end today, I do want to do the Monster Hunter fight.
So that's...
The plan.
Don't get lost?
Yes.
Freeze.
Holy moly.
That was so... close.
Freeze.
Get on the ground.
These guys might suck, but I don't care.
I'm gonna take them home anyway.
Beep, beep.
Now I feel sad.
Wait, what?
Very good.
OK.
The boss used to have the N dress up as Santa, I bet.
Don't say that!
Knightly Liquid never got any Christmas presents because Big Boss thought Santa would do it and just assumed he was a bad child.
That's why he's such a little D-bag.
He's such a stinking weenie.
Because of that.
Oh it's begun!
It's begun!
No!
OK, so for anybody...
For those who don't know...
Zadornov...
There's like a bajillion... It's Endless Eight with Zadornov.
There are so many missions of him escaping, it's actually stupid.
It's the worst part about the game, honestly.
Beep, beep.
It is quite honestly the worst part about the game, but...
You can go.
You can leave.
But yeah, so...
We're gonna have to go through those.
There is a bit more of the game left!
Surprise!
Surprise, there's more of the game!
Surprise.
But we're not gonna do this today.
We are not gonna do that today.
Wait, so then I do...
Item capture 29 again?
Date with pause.
This time blow it up and go to the beach.
OK.
Ah, that's right!
OK, yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's where we see him.
We see the little cat.
Alright, cool.
Thank you.
We're done.
Gotta go to the dock.
OK.
Blow it up and go.
Alright.
Nice, nice, nice.
Calico time.
Where is it?
OK.
Wait, it's over there.
It's the exclamation point.
Freeze.
Get down.
What is behind me?
Wait, which one is it?
Oh, why did I do that?
I'm so dumb.
I wish I could pick this up.
My bad.
Yippee!
Wait.
So it's not the... Wait, I'm lost.
Wait, where am I?
Go to the beach.
You guys, I don't know which way is the beach.
To the beach?
What do you mean?
The play button.
OK, let's see.
That makes more sense than just the beach.
It doesn't say... Ah, this way is to the beach.
OK,
there we go.
I love the beach.
And...
Oh?
Wait.
What did I do wrong?
Where is he?
Maybe it was the Uma dialogue after all.
I have to listen to all of Chico's tapes?
Oh man.
OK, maybe we will do it next time then.
Maybe we will do it next time.
There is still quite a bit to do, so...
Extra Ops 29 complete.
It explains why I never found the Monster Hunter stuff.
I did it before, it's just I can't remember how I did it before.
So these games are so specific in what you have to do sometimes, you know?
Is it all of them for real?
Did I just skip through them?
Why do you say it like that?
Package?
Oh?
Eva...Eva...
What is it?
Under items?
Or...
Other?
Is it actually under the tapes?
Data files?
Oh, a message from Eva.
Holy moly!
She's got a lot to say.
Oh my god.
Oh, wait.
I think I remember this.
Thank you!
Okay.
I think I am done for today though.
What time is it?
Holy cow!
How long have I been...
Oh wow, it's almost been 5 hours.
Wow, but we beat like the first part of Peace Walker, so...
Good job everybody, good job team, good job team!
Oh, I'm big again.
I always play in release order, not chronological order.
Yeah, yeah.
Good job team, good job, good job!
So yeah, there's still quite a bit to go through.
If you couldn't tell, I barely touched the...
I barely touched the codec, the little tapes.
I call them codecs.
The codec tapes.
The information thingies.
We gotta get those Umas.
I like how this is like extra important and I didn't even touch it.
It's okay though.
But yeah, this was fun!
Fun, fun, fun.
Thank you guys!
Oh gosh, maybe we should grab Zdornov while I'm here.
So that when I do other stuff off stream...
He'll be available for next time.
Vic, me too!
Do we wanna do one last battle?
One last thing?
One last Zdornov search?
Zdornov...
Come on in, anybody who wants to join.
Unless you turned off your game...
Turned off your console by now?
Nope, you didn't.
Hello, Micmac.
Yeah, we're good.
Yeah, shouldn't be too hard.
He is just such a pain in the butt, this guy, for real.
He is so stinkin' annoying.
But we'll get him.
I'm happy to grind off stream with you too.
I might post on Twitter and be like...
Hey guys, I'm doing extra ops.
Anybody wanna join?
But maybe, I don't know, maybe next week will be the last.
I don't remember actually how much more we have.
I know it's like...
Obviously I wanna get a date with Kaz.
Because yes, there is a date with Kaz.
And...
We're in Chapter 5, Outer Heaven.
It's a lot of grind.
It is a lot of grinding, I do remember that.
I do remember having before... having to do stuff.
Don't be a stranger if you ever wanna waste extra ops grind stream.
Membu... Yeah, maybe Membu.
I don't know.
Maybe we'll do Membu.
Hello!
Okay, okay.
On the ground with your soldier.
Thanks.
Where is this guy anyway?
This way?
The hay bale.
I want the hay bale.
I love playing this game though.
It's so fun.
Zadornov!
Wait, is there a guy up here?
Who noticed me?
How did they notice?
Who noticed?
Wait, how did they notice?
No backup!
No reinforcements?
Stupid!
Look at this guy.
He doesn't know what's going on.
Come here!
Where is he?
You're gonna regret this!
Is he around here?
Do you know where he is at?
Is he inside this house?
Zadornov!
What did
you do to him?
What did you do to him?
We made it!
It was so silly!
That was actually so...
One second.
There we go.
If it works, it works.
I think we would have gotten an S if it wasn't for the alert phase.
Somebody triggered.
I'll give him something to shoot at.
Nice, so that's our first time finding him.
Who gave this guy a radio anyway?
Oh my god, the way he's like crouched in the corner.
This game is so funny!
I love it, I love it, I love it.
So next time we'll grind a little bit more.
I might grind off stream.
We'll see.
I want to do Monster Hunter next time.
I want to do...
I'll probably try and do a bunch of stuff off stream so that...
Next time, it's all set up.
You know what I mean?
Still more game.
There's still more more game, you guys.
There's still more more game.
More more story even, so...
It's not over yet, but yeah.
Thank you guys for peace walking with me today.
I had a lot of fun, I hope you guys did too.
Sorry I'm chewing, because I'm kind of hungry.
You have to beat all the AI battles to get gods.
Yes, yes.
Yes, I do remember.
So I will require assistance with those.
These bad boys.
I'll never forget I was gaslit into thinking that...
I had to get S rank on Date With Paws, but that was not the case at all.
Wait.
Oh.
It's not Main Ops.
Where are they?
Wait.
Is it Main Ops?
All the vehicle battles?
Oh.
I thought it was the big battles.
I just reached this part today.
Anyway, I've got to go to work.
See you tomorrow.
I just reached this part.
Oh, you copied it twice!
Good luck with the work, Kamibara!
We're ending anyway, so...
After the doorknob.
Oh, I need to unlock more of them.
Yeah, we will.
Because we will keep getting the doorknob missions, of course.
There's a lot of grinding after this part, but we'll get through it.
No worries at all.
Thank you guys.
I hope you guys have a good rest of your Saturday.
Or Sunday, maybe.
Whatever time it is for you.
Have a good day.
Have a good night.
And I'll see you guys later.
Thank you so much for getting through that emotional, beautiful part of Peace Walker.
I love Peace Walker so much.
Thank you so much for the gift.
Thank you!
Bye bye!